so let's talk about why people shrink as
they age especially women women actually
shrink more than men why is that and
what can we do to prevent that you don't
want to wait until you're 2 to 3 inches
or 4 inches shorter and try to reverse
that it's too late ok so we want to act
now so a person potentially could lose a
quarter to a half an inch every decade
after 40 so by the time they're 70 or 80
they're actually 2 or 3 inches shorter
okay why is that and what can we do to
prevent that we're getting a loss of the
disk space between the vertebra and
we're also getting a loss of the
vertebra itself so one of the big myths
out there is that people think that they
can grow bone by drinking more milk
well cows and horses have these huge
legs they're solid they they're
supporting a very large animal and they
don't drink milk after 6 months they
actually are eating grass so there is no
credible study that I could find that
shows that drinking milk will build your
bones or make them stronger
now what about calcium well there's a
problem with calcium especially when if
postmenopausal women take calcium to
prevent bone loss especially if it's
calcium carbonate they increase their
risk of getting heart attacks I did a
separate video on that you can check it
out but when we talk about minerals
we're only talking about one little
piece of the puzzle you need other
minerals you need vitamins you
especially need magnesium and this trace
mineral called boron boron is really
really essential to help prevent
osteopenia and osteoporosis okay so get
your calcium you can get that from leafy
greens and maybe a little high-quality
organic grass-fed dairy okay number two
vitamin d3 and k2 these are fat soluble
vitamins these are really important in
mobilizing and transporting not just
calcium but magnesium as well so vitamin
D helps the absorption of calcium from
the small intestine by 20 times a k2
drives that calcium from the blood into
the bone so vitamin k2 as compared to k1
triggers proteins that keep your bones
really really strong where do you get k2
from well from fatty foods which a lot
of people are on low fat diets and they
don't get enough k2 vitamin d3 you get
it from the Sun but of course as you age
you don't get it nups absorption through
the skin and you have to actually be in
the Sun for a certain amount of time
expose enough of your body to the
sunlight to get what you really need
from vitamin d3 so my recommendation is
to take both of these as a supplement
especially for getting older and you
just want to make sure you're getting
enough to avoid osteopenia things like
that this is a big one number three low
estrogen okay and I'm talking about
women after menopause so when you're low
in estrogen it's gonna be harder to
build bone you actually break bone down
more than you're building it back up but
this is usually coming because the
adrenal glands which are supposed to be
backing up the ovaries during menopause
are not making enough estrogen so you
have the ovaries and the adrenal glands
that make estrogen going into menopause
if your adrenals are too exhausted as an
adrenal fatigue you get this situation
where you get too much cortisol and not
enough estrogen production thus hot
flashes and other problems but cortisol
if too high can create a catabolic
effect and start breaking down bone so
that's one reason why someone might
actually lose their height right there
and then number five low protein they're
not consuming enough high quality
protein you'd be surprised how many
people have a deficiency of protein and
I'm talking about amino acids at least
50% of most protein foods end up as
waste so when you consume protein you
have the quality of protein where it
comes from and then you'll the other
factory of how many essential amino
acids that are in there you're supposed
to have eight essential amino acids if
you're doing collagen for example you
don't even get the eight essential amino
acids so if you don't have those
essential amino acids those building
blocks you cannot build body tissue same
thing with branch amino acids and then
if you don't have enough stomach acid
that's another factor for now digesting
if you have gut issues there's a lot of
issues with
this right here I'll cover this in
another video very soon let's say you're
not exercising okay exercise does help
prevent bone loss because you're adding
a stress and your body is compensating
by making it stronger the whole
structural frame number seven growth
hormone and also something called IGF
number one I want to discuss that and
this next slide is very very important
growth hormone as you age you lose your
ability to make growth hormone
the pituitary makes growth on them and
it works through the liver and then it
triggers this other hormone called igf-1
which has very similar functions to
growth hormone so both of these decrease
as you age so if you're getting older
and you don't have these hormones you
don't get the growth of the bone okay so
what can you do to maximize growth
hormone
you can keep your insulin low and your
Sugar's low
hmm that sounds like keto to me okay
next one you want to get more sleep okay
and less stress that will increase
growth hormone as well in fact a good
amount of the growth hormone is elevated
while you're sleeping in the deep
delta-wave sleep so if you're not
sleeping you're not going to be able to
produce enough growth hormone and that's
when all the repair happens all the
recovery and actual bone growth itself
exercise high-intensity interval
training has the potential to increase
growth hormone by 700 percent but this
is mainly if you're doing some hardcore
sprinting so if you're not doing
hardcore sprinting it could be less than
that and realize everyone's different
and this was just one study so it could
be less it could be a little bit more
but high-intensity interval training is
the way to go but do it graduate first
so you don't overdo it vitamin D very
important and increasing growth hormone
lots of Sun or take it as a supplement
but this right here is probably the most
potent stimulator of growth hormone and
that's intermittent fasting you can
increase growth hormone by 1,300 to
2000% when you do in a minute fasting so
again intamin fasting will help you get
younger and in talking about your bones
as well so the more the story is don't
wait until you're 2 to 3 to 4 inches
shorter do something now as a
preventative measure if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos